sie haben einen offenen brief an herrn
scholz geschrieben dann haben sie auch
direkt unterstützer gefunden wohin geht
es in paris um eine klare position für
eine entschiedene eine energische
unterstützung der ukraine in ihrem
abwehrkampf gegen den russischen krieg
gegen den russischen überfall und das
heißt lieferung auch schwerer waffen die
unterscheidung zwischen defensiv und
offensiv waffen macht gar keinen sinn in
einem verteidigungskrieg sind alle
waffen defensive waffen das heißt auch
eine klare europäische
beitrittsperspektive für die ukraine ich
meine kein land hat einen höheren preis
bezahlt um mitglied des demokratischen
des freien europa zu werden und es heißt
verschärfte ökonomisches sanktionen
gegen russland und putin die finanzen
für diesen krieg zu entziehen
mal sehen was ist aus dem guten alten
frieden schaffen ohne waffen geworden
sie sind diese kommen doch eigentlich
aus der pazifistischen
ecke ursprünglicher mal oder ich war nie
pazifist und das gewaltfreie der grünen
bei ihrer gründung war auch vor allem
eine selbstverpflichtung also gewaltfrei
zu sein in der politischen
auseinandersetzung das wahrsagen noch
ein echo auf die raf und an den
politischen terrorismus zu sagen wir
wollen eine zivile politische kultur
aber international hatten die grünen
zumindest immer zwei denkschulen eine
die tatsächlich sagte frieden schaffen
ohne waffen und eine sagte man muss auch
bereits sein gegen massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen gegen
verletzungen des völkerrechts gegen
aggressive mächte mit militärischer
gegengewalt zu antworten zumindest zur
abschreckung er wirklich offener brief
erscheint ja morgen in der zeit print
online ist ja schon da wie schwer war es
denn mitunterzeichner zu finden gar
nicht schwer
wir hatten etwa einen tag zeit um
unterstützerin für diese offene brief zu
finden sind jetzt auf den ersten schub
schriftstellerin
ja wissenschaftler ehemalige politische
größen wie gerhard baum und man spürte
richtig es gab einen bedarf dafür der
boden war reif dafür eine antwort auf
diesen ersten offenen brief von alice
schwarzer und andere ja sagten
entwaffnet die ukrainisch wir haben
gestern hier genau an diesen tisch
gemerkt wie hoch die emotionen
eigentlich sind sowie schwarzers brief
eine frau die ihn heute widersprechen
würde es ulrike gewohnt da waren wir
einmal kurz reinschauen was sie gestern
eigentlich dazu gesagt hat ich glaube
tatsächlich dass die briefe welle
ausgelöst hat und ich stehe voll
umfänglich zu den brief wie ich
getwittert habe warum weil wenn wir auf
dieses leid gucken von mario pohl den
krankenhäusern butscher und so weiter
dann kann ich nur sagen cicero der
ungerechteste frieden ist besser als der
gerechteste krieg ja und wenn wir uns
jetzt um dieses leid bemühen diese
bilder nicht haben wollen dann müssen
wir frieden machen frieden machen
schrieben machen
ich würde sagen liebe ulrike baro das
ist richtige verkehrung der tatsachen
sie macht die angegriffenen
verantwortlich für die opfer ja also die
ukraine die sich selbst verteidigt die
ist dafür das leid der zivilbevölkerung
verantwortlich stadt diejenigen
anzugehen die diesen krieg vom zaun
gebrochen haben gegen ein friedliches
sein nachbarland und der ukraine das
recht auf selbstverteidigung
abzusprechen das empfinde ich als eine
art von zynismus und als moralische
bevormundung zu der wir null recht haben
wenn man daran denkt wie der deutschen
nationalsozialismus niedergerungen
werden musste nämlich mit militärischer
gewalt klar ist würdest du zustimmen
würdest du vielleicht sogar als naiv
bezeichnet
das würde ich nicht ich finde diese
debatte unheimlich wichtig weil sie
laut und deutlich geführt wird und es
ist toll dass es im land möglich ist
sich aus zwei diametral
unterschiedlichen perspektiven diese
furchtbaren auseinandersetzung zu nehmen
ich bin von meiner ganzen verankerung
näher bei sozusagen ihren brief und
ihnen aber ein gedanke treibt mich dabei
immer um die idee basiert ja darauf zu
sagen wirtschaftssanktionen damit
stabilisiert man russland von innen und
ermächtigung und der tüchtigen der
ukraine zur selbstverteidigung mit
waffen ich verwende zwar eine vokabel
immer mehr waffen sozusagen und immer
besser machen so glaubt man also kann
man putin in die knie zwingen aber was
ist wenn das nicht klappt also wie ist
quasi die eskalation dieses gedankens
noch mehr waffen noch schärfere
sanktionen noch mehr waffen noch
schärfer sein was ist eigentlich wenn
die ukrainische armee in die knie geht
dann soldaten wäre ja die gleiche logik
dann schicken wir soldaten damit die
ukraine sich selber verteidigen an der
an der stelle da bin ich das verstehe
ich rechtlich natürlich aber ich finde
wenn man den gedanken die mir nahe ist
den ich auch unterschreiben würde weiter
denkt kommt man in ein gewässer in ein
fahrwasser wo plötzlich der ein oder
andere gedanke der anderen nicht mehr
naiv sondern vielleicht einfach nur
menschenfreundlich erscheint jetzt wird
man putin und die russische armee nicht
stärker machen als sie sind ja die
ukraine hat sich im gegen alle
erwartungen erfolgreich verteidigt gegen
den ersten anlauf der russischen armee
kiew eine art blitzkrieg zur u-bahn ist
hätte fast niemand sagen erwartet und
sie halten auch jetzt obwohl sie viel
schlechter ausgerüstet sind der
russische offensive im süden und osten
des landes
stand also die ukrainer selbst sind
überzeugt dass sie in der lage sein
werden diesen krieg zu gewinnen wenn sie
die hinreichende unterstützung bekommt
und wir müssen gegenüber russland sehr
klar signalisieren dass wir die ukraine
nicht fallen lassen
aber es ist noch nicht genau die antwort
auf meine sorge also meine sorge ist es
klappt nicht nicht in einem monat in
zwei seiner intelligenten vor monaten
nicht in acht monaten in keinem krieg
gibt es eine gewähr ich meine wusste
churchill als er sagte wir werden nicht
kapitulieren
wusste er wie die sache ausgeht oder de
gaulle als er zur résistance aufgerufen
hat gegen die deutsche besatzung in
frankreich
auch die sowjetunion als sie angegriffen
wurde war eigentlich einer unterlegenen
position also
wenn sie eine hundertprozentige garantie
für einen militärischen sieg haben
wollen dann kann es gleich lassen dann
muss man die waffen von anfang an
strecken aber das ist eine option die
für die ukraine nicht real ist weil was
ist putins ziel explizit die vernichtung
der eigenständigkeit der ukraine als
nation ja und wenn man gesehen hat was
sie in mariupol angerichtet haben was
sie jetzt mit den zivilisten machen die
aus den belagerten städten kommen sie
nämlich
auszusortieren im solche die in russland
in kabul lagerverwaltung kommen und
solche die dann zurückgehen könnte
eckstein und das ist natürlich die
glauben sie denn dass mit schweren
waffen der krieg ja aufzuhalten zu
gewinnen das für die ukraine das weiß
ich nicht also ich meine das was herr
strunz gehalt gesagt hat ist ja richtig
sozusagen dann ist die logik irgendwann
bot tags und man schickt immer mehr und
mehr und mehr worum es mir geht ist
jetzt wir haben jetzt zwei briefe also
die antwort ist nicht ja oder nein wo
für mich persönlich muss ich ganz
ehrlich gestehen emotional sage ich gebt
ihnen alles was sie brauchen aber es
gibt ja noch andere faktoren und mir
geht es ja nicht alleine nur so sondern
ganz deutschland geht so es gibt in
deutschland trend 45 prozent dafür 45
dagegen also wirklich halb halb durch
ist übrigens gesunken im april waren
noch anfang april waren noch 55 prozent
der deutschland wegen dieser losen reden
vom drohenden atomkrieg natürlich aber
die leute haben angst das darf man ja
wohl nachvollziehen dass die schüler
nicht sage ich nicht und es gibt
situationen in denen man sich
entscheiden muss sind doch politiker
nehmen ja oder nein sagen muss und dich
irgend eine bequeme position in der
mitte von jahr aber in der ukraine ist
die frage lassen wir sie fallen lassen
wir zu dass eine großmacht die auch noch
mitglied im sicherheitsrat der vereinten
nationen ist und eigentlich das
völkerrecht waren und schützen müsste
eine andere überfällt um mir ihren
willen aufzuzwingen oder tun wir alles
damit putin diesen krieg nicht gewinnt
das verstehe ich alles das gehe ich
alles mit der punkt um den es mehr geht
ist ich weiß es ist krieg in der ukraine
und das muss jetzt schnell gehen aber
offensichtlich gibt es den bedarf in der
gesellschaft zu diskutieren wollen nun
das ja oder nein sozusagen die friedens
machen wir ja immer beschworen wurde und
so jetzt ist die zeitenwende da wir sind
plötzlich ganz anders wir stellen uns
mit anderen setzen uns mit anderen
themen auseinander und anderen logik das
ist ja für uns deutsche was ganz neues
also in so einer situation waren wir
noch nie jetzt dass wir zum beispiel
nummer 1 anna wir haben sagen die
nato-intervention damals in bosnien nach
drei jahren irgendwie zugeguckt haben
wir haben kosovo uns beteiligt wir haben
uns in afghanistan beteiligt wir haben
auch auslandseinsätze mali ist jetzt
nicht so aber keine abwägung wo wir
selbst angst haben müssen so zu sagen
was passiert wenn russland die
konfrontation eskaliert was hat das für
uns deutsche so also vor den serben vor
herrn müller sowie das musste mal keiner
sorge haben in berlin wir mal ganz kurz
bei denen wir zu recht gesagt dass eine
ja oder nein frage also sind sie auf der
seite als sanktionen und waschen oder
auf der neuen seite ja in der regel aber
mit großen bauchschmerzen und ich
verstehe jeden der sagt ich habe angst
davor frau schwarzer hat angst sie hat
es verklausuliert formuliert sozusagen
der brief ist aber ein jahr die abgesagt
sie hatte noch nie in ihrem leben seit
sie geboren ist so viel angst vor drei
jahren nach und weil wir angst haben
opfern über die ukraine nein ich mache
gern bereit das muss man abwarten
weltkrieg zu gehen für die oder
kriegspartei zuweilen die frage ein
großartiges diw sieht sie sagen dass sie
sagen gerade wurde er whatever it takes
müssen wir müssen mehr unterstützen das
heißt auch wie klaus auch vorhin gesagt
hatte in letzter konsequenz heißt dass
die kriegspartei werden und wenn wir
jetzt auch schon die rhetorik der
amerikanischen verteidigungsministers
anhören sagt er ist die ist das ziel
nicht nur die verteidigung der
souveränität von der ukraine sondern er
sagt wir müssen einen punkt kommen dass
russland nie wieder in die lage kommt
ein anderes land zu überfallen das heißt
nicht dass die als offizielle kriegsziel
der weg des westens ist inzwischen nicht
die verteidigung der ukraine nicht mehr
nur sondern auch russland zu schwächen
also da werden wir zur kriegspartei wir
sind längst dabei das zu tun mit den
ökonomischen sanktionen ja die branche
wir wollen da oft aus russischem öl und
gas aussteigen das sind 40 prozent des
staatshaushalts was ist das anderes als
eine politik die sagt wir werden euch
wirtschaftlich finanziell so schwächen
dass wir nicht mehr daran ist weiter
sagte geht im also der beiden ruft offen
zur zum regime wechsel auf was ich sag
nur also ich bin ehrlich gegen diese
ganzen fragen komplett ratlos ich würde
wieder den einen noch den anderen brief
unterscheiden ich bin aber auch
familiär ein bisschen traumatisiert zwar
meine uhr urgroßtante die in sarajevo
erschossen wurde und das hätte er hätte
den hätte den meisten menschen europa
ähnlich egal sein können dass ein
unbeliebter thronfolger und seinen genau
so unbeliebte ehefrau in guitar hero
erschossen wird aber zehn millionen
junge menschen sind deswegen in dem in
den kriegs gräben in den schützengräben
gestorben und was mich beunruhigt ist so
ein bisschen
diese
der fachbegriff ist polizist muss und
ich finde dass es zu übersetzen mit mit
kriegslüsterne als übertrieben aber der
enthusiasmus immer mehr waffen immer
mehr waffen und jetzt auch noch rust ein
putin stürzen und russland schwächen ich
habe dagegen eine unterirdische rhetorik
wer vertritt hier enthusiasmus wer zieht
mit begeisterung in den krieg niemand
sondern das ist ein auf gezwungener
krieg für die ukraine und für die
europäische union wir müssen uns
entscheiden ob wir akzeptieren dass die
europäische friedensordnung die auf
bestimmten regeln passiert nämlich
gleich souveränität aller staaten keine
gewaltsame veränderung von von grenzen
natürlich menschenrechte hat noch die
alte sowjetunion im helsinki protokoll
akzeptiert als grundlage der
europäischen ordnung ob das alles über
den haufen geworfen wird und zukünftig
das recht des stärkeren herrscht dass
auch eine gefahr für unsere sicherheit
ganz ihrer meinung nur und es geht nicht
darum dass wir jetzt die bundeswehr nach
in die ukraine schicken sondern es geht
darum dass wir die ukraine so stärken
dass sie standhalten kann das wäre
jedenfalls möchte mich noch ein bisschen
von dieser ein bisschen 1914 stimmung
wir tun das sie sind auf der seite das
gegenteil ist eine angst stimmung in der
republik ist es überhaupt keine hurra
sagen stimmung für wir ziehen in den
krieg sondern es ist eine stimmung der
furcht aber wenn wir uns von furcht
treiben lassen dann machen wir uns
komplett erpressbar sobald putin auch
nur andeutet es gebe die möglichkeit
atomwaffen einzusetzen
geben wir ihm freie hand und das freie
zwischen freier hand und kriegspartei
werden ist ja noch ist ja noch mal ein